campos hasta donde alcanza la vista en
el noroeste de yemen los agricultores
están ocupados cosechando y moliendo el
trigo antes de enviarlo a todo el país
un producto esencial para los 30
millones de habitantes
esencial pero insuficiente porque el
país suele depender de sus importaciones
éstas están en riesgo al estar
amenazadas por la guerra de ucrania
toast amarra al granero y la guerra
entre rusia y ucrania continúa el precio
de trigo volverá a subir y luego están
los precios del petróleo si siguen
subiendo los costes de transporte
también aumentarán y esto se transmitirá
a la población la tierra de fútbol de
ucrania y rusia son los grandes
exportadores de productos agrícolas y
especialmente de trigo pero con la
guerra no pueden producir tanto como
antes resultado las cantidades
disponibles disminuyen y sus precios
aumentan
de momento podemos encontrar la harina
pero tememos que se nos acabe por eso
pedimos a los comerciantes que importen
cantidades suficientes y hacemos un
llamado a las autoridades competentes
para que ayuden a los agricultores a
cultivar trigo en nuestro país e
intenten alcanzar la autosuficiencia
bíblica
la lectura de aquí en la situación es
especialmente preocupante para yemen
pues la economía del país ya está
devastada por siete años de guerra civil
la población está al borde de la
inanición tanto es así que según la onu
casi dos terceras partes de la población
podría necesitar ayuda alimentaria
durante el segundo semestre